like just like what what's your thoughts
on this like as far as like the
viability maybe the potential or is
there something we're not seeing you
know that you say hey you know what this
could work with their ego so just what's
your personal thoughts on this potential
rollout because they look like they're
linking this with this you know this
other Hardware as well as PS5 Pro
eventually
I I
think it's only viable depending on the
price and that's it and that's it
um
towards the end of the year with this
new console which with the disk drive
I'm assuming it's going to be just like
the regular price of the PS5 at the
moment like 500 if this
handheld is gonna just be an accessory
and it's going to be 150 and then you
bundle you bundle that with the
PlayStation 5 for 650.